[Music]
cruise ships a symbol of mass tourism
they bring in tourists and cash
but overtourism also creates many
problems the pandemic was a respite for
overrun cities and villages but it also
caused huge economic problems for those
depending on tourism is there a middle
way
how to balance sustainable and
profitable tourism
[Music]
that's a big question welcome to our
cowboy 19 special i'm monica jones good
to have you with us
solitude and peace and quiet in the
countryside the pandemic made that kind
of holiday very appealing
even croatia a beach destination for sun
worshipers across europe is now showing
a new face greener and relaxing
you can see four countries from this
hill in croatia
austria slovenia hungary and slovakia
all of these countries are fighting for
tourists at the moment as is croatia
in 2012 when nina novencich bought an
old dilapidated house to fix up no one
guessed that tourism would play such an
important role here
we can't offer our guests sun and sea so
we have to offer other things
we have to offer quality think of new
ideas and constantly improve and expand
so that we can attract guests
in 2019 croatia recorded a record high
of 21 million tourists in 2020 the year
after pandemic the numbers of typical
tourists collapsed before nina and her
husband zlatko there was a bright side
we had more to do last year than ever
before
the wine region in the north of croatia
suddenly became an attraction
we offer our guests security privacy and
closeness to nature
an idyllic green sport just for
themselves that's what their guests were
looking for in the pandemic
it's quite common for people to come
here on the way back from the coast to
recover
to recover from the chaos from
everything that they experienced down
there from the noise and throngs of
people
don't know another advantage
agro-tourism works all year round not
just in summer
yeah
i hope that this trend will last and we
shouldn't forget that tourism actually
causes a lot of problems
we tended to forget that before the
coronavirus crisis
in many places tourism destroyed the
exact thing that made the destination so
popular in the first place
many people in croatia lost their jobs
in the tourism industry due to the
coronavirus
but the crisis also inspired new
reflections
to relax and recover you don't always
need a beachside resort
sometimes you need just the opposite
let's bring in irena atelievic from the
institute of tourism in zagreb a public
institute in croatia specializing in
research and consultancy services in
tourism and claudia dolezal a professor
at the department of business at imc
university crems her research focuses on
tourism in southeast asia and it's good
to have both of you on the programme
irena peace and solitude that's what
holidaymakers were seeking during the
pandemic also in croatia do you think
that this trend will last or will people
eventually fall back into old habits
i think that um pandemic definitely
serves as a typical point to for
travelers to finally commit to their own
sustainable journey is actually the
latest booking.com research i get it
from more than 29 000 travelers across
30 countries shows that with
a 72 percent of global travelers believe
uh people have to act now to save the
planet for future generations they are
more than ever committed to do so in a
mindful way to travel
and stating that the pandemic has
influenced them to want to travel more
sustainably in the future and almost
half admitting that
pandemic has shifted their attitude to
make positive changes in their everyday
lives
is that something that you also observe
in south east asia claudia we know that
uh the pandemic hit the region hard some
34 million people there lost the job
last year uh how how can they adapt to
an eventual new form of tourism
yeah as you say the region has really
been hit very hard by tourism and it's
highly dependent on tourism as we know
and people have lost their livelihoods
even left the sector all together but
slowly the situation is improving and
countries are opening up
such as in thailand with the sandbox
project in phuket a very interesting
development happening here which is a
development where we're isolating
tourists again in their tourist bubbles
in resorts
a kind of mass tourism that has been
criticized in the past
and here in this region we're also
seeing digital nomads being targeted
quite strongly to stay for a few months
or even years and
we have to consider these are very
diffic different tourists
um
there might not be responsible ones yeah
in what way are they different
uh they're different because they
obviously have different needs they're
staying much longer they're working
they're not the traditional tourists
we're seeing and they're definitely very
different from other tourists that are
being targeted like domestic tourists or
the high quality tourists that
thailand is trying to target rather than
the backpacker that actually gives more
money to local communities and the rural
countryside and the home stays yeah
i think we really have to think about
sustainability here and we have to also
be realistic that southeast asia is a
region that can't just target the
wealthy traveler but also must target
those uh backpackers they have done
before
right so so
when we take this uh lesson learned if
you like back to europe irena what
lessons can we learn from this pandemic
both for for the tourists and for the
people whose livelihood depends on
tourism what kind of tourism will be
sustainable
tourism that is more localized more
regenerated that connects to local
community to the nature that regenerates
places and resources on the basis of
which tourism actually depends and this
is the trend that we see now for more
conscious travelers who um experiencing
the isolation of pandemic realize how
much they miss the nature how much they
really
need healthy food and healthy lifestyle
indeed more peace and the solitude and
this is an excellent opportunity for
tourism to totally reset what they say
to rebuild the back better and to become
more socially environmentally
sustainable and in europe we have this
incredible opportunity for the fact that
we are the the key a global market and
it can become a much more localized and
regionalized that it can contribute to
more sustainable um future not only of
tourism but
of our economies and the planet
claudia would that work for southeast
asia as well
yeah i do believe so and uh definitely
sustainable tourism is the only option
forward here in this in this region we
need innovative ideas now we need to
move away from this dependency tourism
has created that actual towards actually
diversifying economies more and creating
linkages
but again this crisis has shown us the
huge inequalities that we see in in the
world in terms of privilege to travel
and health system and access to
government funding so unfortunately it's
developing countries that have been hit
hardest but i also think there is a new
energy here and innovative ideas that
can be used to actually make tourism
better
all right dr irena atelier from the
institute of tourism in zagreb and
claudia dolezal from icm university
crems in austria thank you so much for
your time
and time now for one of your questions
and it's over again to our science
correspondent derek williams
can we prevent future variants from
arising with restrictions vaccinations
and lockdowns
like other pathogens the coronavirus
that causes covet 19 is constantly
mutating which is a natural process of
genetic change
that's as old as evolution itself
mutation gives rise to new variants and
the vast majority of them
are less competitive than the variants
now circulating widely
but a few could prove to be more
competitive whether
in terms of transmissibility like delta
or potentially in terms of for instance
immune escape
to some extent therefore
it's a numbers game every time someone
is infected it means
the evolutionary wheel of fortune starts
to spin and the chances grow a little
more likely
that the wheel will eventually land on a
variant
that would be harder to fight than the
variants that we currently face but the
reverse is also true every time that we
prevent an infection through the
measures that we take
it does a little bit to limit the
opportunities the virus has to evolve
and that's a vital
long-term aspect of measures like
restrictions and vaccinations and
lockdowns that's that's often forgotten
i think
of course we take all of those measures
to protect ourselves and and also to try
to prevent others from getting a disease
that could [ __ ]
or even kill us
but by limiting the spread of sars kobe
2
we're also helping to slow the pace of
evolution in the virus since
how quickly potentially dangerous
variants arise
is directly linked to how many
opportunities that the virus has to
replicate so so while we can't
necessarily prevent future dangerous
variants from rising with prevention and
mitigation measures entirely
they do help us to reduce the chances
that the evolutionary wheel of fortune
might land on one
[Music]